we left cocos island today with
personnel from the conservation
organization Marv Eva a Coco's park
ranger and a cause your officer in
search for the biggest threat to our
ocean we follow the small Costa Rican
boat fishing more than 350 miles south
of the mainland
this fisherman and your many hardship
and struggle to make a living out of
increasingly scare resources for men 500
hooks and only one fish
a hapless Dorado once a golden living
treasure crusing the Seas like a torpedo
a meager trophy which shows how the
cleated fish populations are inside the
Coco's National Park however marine
light is foraging but tomorrow we'll
witness something in the park that broke
our hearts
you